Okay.
Hi everyone.
Welcome to the September version of my q
and a's and uh,
thank you very much for tuning in again.
Um,
hopefully we'll have an interesting
discussion tonight.
I want to stop start that is with a
demonstration of some new newly managed
technical wizardry.
I have a program that I developed with
my colleagues that I want to talk to you
guys about for just a few seconds.
Some of you already know about this
called self authoring and self authoring
helps people write about their past to
guide it autobiography,
that's the past authoring program and to
write about their virtues and their
faults.
That's there's to present autherine
programs and a future authoring program
that helps people write out a vision and
a destination,
let's say an ethical destination for
their lives as well as formulate a plan
to put that vision into,
to make that vision into reality.
And our experimental investigations have
indicated,
for example,
that university students who complete
this program,
even if they do it badly and I would
recommend at least doing it badly,
increase their probability of staying at
university by about 30% and it has a
positive effect on their grade point
average as well.
So there's a fair bit of evidence that
your personality is organized at the
highest level through articulated
speech.
Some of that you can formulate
internally by thinking in some of it you
have to do,
you can do by writing.
You also do that in discussion with
other people.
But these programs are designed to break
down the problem of articulating your
life in the past,
present and future into a series of
steps that are at least in principle
manageable.
And the thousands of people have done
them and I think they're very helpful
programs and uh,
we spent a lot of time perfecting them I
suppose to the degree that they are
perfected.
Anyways,
I want to,
here's the high tech part of this.
You see that's the website self
authoring.com and I put a coupon
together.
Um,
the coupon name is September.
So that's what you have to enter for the
coupon.
And that gives you a 20% discount at
self authoring.
So,
and now all this is even more high tech
because this marker is in a different
color.
And this program is a personality test
based on the big five aspect scale,
which is a scale that calling the young
one of my students developed when he
worked in my lab along with Lena quilty.
And uh,
the big five aspects scale offers you a
five dimensional readout of your
personality,
extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness and openness,
the classic big five.
And then it breaks each of the factors,
each of the traits into two aspects.
So you get a high resolution map of your
personality that takes the,
takes about a hundred questions,
takes about 15 minutes to do and you'll
learn about yourself.
I think you'll learn interesting things.
I had my kids do repeated iterations of
the big five aspects scale when they
were teenagers.
And I learned a lot about them even
though I thought I knew them quite well.
I learned things that were very useful.
So you can do that and maybe you'll
understand yourself a little bit better.
And so
this is the site
and the coupon is September,
just as it was for self authoring.
And that's 20% as well.
Okay.
And you'll see that amazingly enough,
this advertisement,
I suppose,
which is what it is,
is in purple instead of blue.
And so that's another technological
miracle brought to you by the Internet
and the intelligence of modern human
beings.
So all right,
so we've dispensed with that.
So that's self authoring and understand
myself and you might find those useful
and I hope you do so onto more,
um,
von to different things.
I guess I just got back to Toronto
yesterday,
I think it was yesterday.
I was out in western Canada.
I went to a family reunion on Vancouver
Island and then a reunion of sorts as
well in Saskatchewan with my side of the
family and uh,
finished the talk and Regina and went
into saskatoon as well,
which seemed to be relatively well
received.
So hurray for that.
I've really enjoyed all these lectures
that I've been giving.
And tammy and I,
Tammy's my wife,
we visited 65 cities now on this tour
and we're starting again on September
5th we're going to go down the eastern
seaboard.
There's 20 cities in,
in the northeastern us.
And then we're off to Europe for another
15 cities or so.
And then in February I think we're going
to go to Australia.
And then in March and April back to
Europe.
And then in May,
I'm going to spend four months
diligently finishing up what I hope to
be my next book,
if assuming that I can get that done in
that period of time.
And also that other opportunities,
let's say,
or distractions don't rear their head
either positively or negatively.
And who knows,
right?
Because life is a very uncertain
business.
I've really enjoyed the lecture tour a
lot.
Um,
you know,
I've been speaking to audiences of about
2,500 to 3000 people and mostly about
the,
I would say mostly about the nexus,
the relationship between meaning and
responsibility,
trying to make the case that because
life is difficult as everyone with any
sense knows.
And because we can make that worse with
our own stupidity and malevolence that
it's necessary to find a sustaining
meaning in life.
And my sense is,
and I think people tend to agree to
this,
is that the most sustaining meaning can
be found a and the adoption of voluntary
responsibility.
So in attempts to decrease the suffering
in life and to do things that are
worthwhile and admirable and to take
care of yourself individually and your
family,
and to have a little bit leftover for
your community and to have goodwill
across all those dimensions if you can
possibly manage it despite the fact that
there is something in life to make
people relatively bitter.
And then,
um,
as well the necessity of conducting
yourself in a truthful manner.
Um,
making also the case to my listeners,
I suppose that that one of the most
ancient presuppositions that underlies
the structure of Western civilization,
which is a very functional civilization
in my estimation,
is the idea derived from genesis,
that truthful speech,
if you confront truthful speech,
if you confront potential,
the chaos and potential that is in front
of you with truthful speech,
that you engender the order that is
good.
And that's a fundamental ethical dictum.
It's,
it's,
it's a presupposition in some sense that
the order that you bring into existence
in all the choices that you make will be
the best possible order in proportion to
the degree that you conduct yourself in
a truthful manner.
And so those ideas seem to be falling on
very receptive ears and they are the
most resilient ideas that I think I've
ever come across.
I mean,
I always take an ice pick and a hammer
to any idea that I encounter and I
really do that diligently because I
don't want to rely on ideas that can
fall apart and break,
especially when they're stressed.
And I don't see,
I don't,
I haven't come across ideas that are
more solid than that.
I mean,
the first proposition,
you know that life is suffering and that
we make it worse with our malevolence.
I think everyone understands that to be
true.
But the second is that the best way to
confront that is to shoulder
responsibility voluntarily and to live
in truth.
I think those are even more powerful
ideas because you could say that the
cure for a malaise or the treatment for
a disease is more powerful than the
Malaysia Malays or the disease itself.
And If responsibility and truth are
antidotes to suffering and malevolence,
then that means that they're there.
They have a power that's transcendent
over suffering malevolence and you know,
it's so,
it's a very pessimistic viewpoint.
On the one hand,
because I'm stressing for everybody that
is coming to listen to me talk the fact
that life has an inalienable element of
difficulty and,
and travail and suffering and all of
that,
and you certainly see that sort of thing
when you go to a family reunion.
You know,
like a lot of my relatives,
my parents generation,
they're getting,
all of my parents are in their eighties
now and,
and their friends,
some of,
they have friends that are older and
everyone's starting to suffer from the
inevitable deterioration that's
associated with old age.
And it's very,
very trying and very difficult for
people.
And it's,
it's in those situations that you see
more clearly the fragility of life and
also the importance of having,
uh,
having a family that's functional and
people around you that love you and all
those things that in principle can help
sustain you through difficult times.
So anyways,
I'm here in Toronto for about 10 days,
got a lot of media interviews again
partly to discuss the upcoming talks.
Um,
my book 12 rules for life still appears
to be selling extraordinarily well.
Um,
it's quite
amazing.
All things considered.
Um,
it's approaching 2 million sales and in
the English version.
And um,
there are foreign versions coming out
all the time.
So,
and I've also,
I'm also in the process of putting
together the final arrangements for my
next book,
which I talked about.
So the plan is to,
to,
right,
I'm writing that now.
I've got it about half written,
maybe a little bit more expanding on the
themes that I developed in 12 rules for
life and also extending them as much as
I possibly can.
Um,
and I hope to continue writing during
this period of touring as well so that I
can stay on top of my deadlines and then
from May to September to spend most of
that time finalizing and editing and
polishing and all of that.
And then hopefully the book is due in
September and the current plan is to
spend September through December,
um,
likely concentrating on a return to the
biblical lectures starting with exodus,
which is something I'm really looking
forward to but haven't really been able
to turn my hand to.
The other thing I'm really thinking hard
about doing,
I'd like to do a series of lectures.
I don't know if I could do them publicly
or not,
but I might be able to finagle that in
some manner.
I'd like to do a series of lectures on
the sacred icons of the radical left.
So I'd like to do a lecture series on
Marx and foucault and Derrida,
and then some,
some of the famous feminist too,
like betty for Dan whose work I'm not a
fan of,
um,
for a variety of reasons and do Judith
Butler as well.
But I'd really like to concentrate on
marks.
So,
uh,
one of the things I might duty for you
guys tonight or two you have,
one of the things I might do to you
tonight is I found a poem by Karl Marx
that is extraordinarily interesting and
uh,
that might be worth reading if I can.
I just thought about doing that if I can
scrape it up in time.
So let me just check very quickly and
see if I can find it and then I'll get
to some questions because after all,
this is a q and a,
right?
That's the theory.
So
give me 30 seconds if you can indulge
me.
There it is.
Yeah.
So let me read this to you and then
we'll get to the Q.
And.
A.
I think this,
this is the kind of thing that I'd like
to shed light on in any possible lecture
series on marks.
So this is called invocation
invocation of one in despair.
So God has snatched from me my all in
the curse and rack of destiny.
Oh,
his worlds are gone beyond recall
nothing but revenge is left to me on
myself.
Revenge all proudly wreak on that.
Being that in thrown Lord make my
strength of patchwork of what's week.
Leave my better self without reward,
I shall build my throne.
High overhead,
cold,
tremendous shell at summit be for it's
bulwark,
superstitious dread for it's Marshall,
blackest agony who looks on it with a
healthy I shall turn back struck
definitely pale and dumb clutched by
blind and chill mortality me,
his happiness prepare his too.
And the Almighty's lightning shell
rebound from that massive iron giant.
If he bring my walls and towers down,
eternity shall raise them up defiant.
Well,
so on that happy note,
that's perhaps perhaps some insight into
the spirit that motivated our friend Mr
Carl Marx.
So,
okay.
I've really been thinking a lot about
the Marxist critique of Western culture,
especially the fundamental,
um,
Marxist critique is something eight
fundamental mark Marxist critique is a
criticism of the fact that in capitalist
societies,
uh,
a disproportionate amount of the spoils,
let's say the wealth goes to a
disproportionately small part of the
community.
And this is of course a truism by the
way,
it is the case that that occurs,
which is why the richest dozen people in
the world have as much money as the
bottom 2 billion,
something like that.
Um,
it's also the case,
it's part of a more generalized law
sometimes called prices law and
represented with the prieto
distribution.
Prieto is p a r e t o showing that not
only do the bulk of the spoils,
let's say the wealth go to a
disproportionately small number of
people,
but the bulk of the productive work is
also done by a disproportionately small
number of people,
not necessarily the same people that
have the wealth,
by the way,
although in a functional society,
there's some overlap.
Now mark's was correct and observing
that that happened in capitalist
societies,
but incorrect in assuming that there are
any societies that have ever been
formulated or that could ever be
formulated that would escape from that
destiny.
Because you see that same tremendous
pareto distribution,
that proclivity of wealth to,
to accrue in the hands of small of a
small number of people.
You see that in every human society
that's ever been studied.
And if it's not wealth,
it's sexual access or reproductive well
that's the same thing.
Reproductive Opportunity,
let's say,
or,
or material possessions,
which is obviously a form of wealth,
et cetera.
So one of the things that characterizes
the west is that all our,
although our society's produced
inequality,
like every other society,
including animal societies,
by the way,
and even among plants,
even among stars,
a disproportionate number of the
heavenly bodies have most of the mass by
the way,
which is not something that you can lay
at the feet of western capitalism.
Um,
the thing that the West has been able to
do
that other societies haven't been able
to do is to produce wealth along with
inequality.
And that wealth is definitely
a fair proportion of that wealth is
actually going to benefit the people who
are in the diaries straights and not
processes been accelerating over the
last 20 years.
So from the year 2000 till the year 2012
the level of absolute poverty in the
world is halved,
which is the fastest rate of economic
development in the history of the world.
And I think that rate is accelerating,
at least in part because the Soviet
Union,
for example,
isn't around anymore to agitate the
economic masters in leaders of
developing countries into the adoption
of counterproductive collectivist
economic strategies.
And so what appears to be happening is
that as we spread the fundamental
western ethos of individuality and
private property and free markets and
freedom in general for men and for women
around the world,
that the poorest people are becoming,
well at least they're not starving.
They're becoming richer,
even though at the same time we do pay a
price for that in inequality.
So there's a rule and I don't know how
to formulate it exactly or there seems
to be a rule which is a given unit of
wealth is produced at the cost of,
of certain production of inequality,
a certain number of units of inequality,
and that seems to be inalienable to some
degree.
So anyways,
that's part of a Marxist critique the
poem first,
which is like you want to listen to that
poem a couple of times I would say,
but then more fundamentally a critique
of the Marxist critique of the West.
Yes,
the West produces inequality,
but it's not something that you could
lay at the feet of capitalism.
It's a much,
much deeper problem.
And what that means too is that those
people who purport to be on the side of
the poor and dispossessed are not being
friends to them by any stretch of the
imagination at all by attempting to tear
down the very hierarchies that seemed to
be leveraging the world's poorest people
out of poverty as rapidly as possible.
There's evidence as well that people
start to become very concerned about the
environment.
If you can get their family income.
I think arts,
GDP,
I think up about 40,
above about 4,500 us a year,
they start to have a little bit of spare
time to be concerned with the
environment around them.
And so the right way to,
to ecological balance in the world seems
to be,
um,
to make people rich as fast as we
possibly can to make the poor rich as
fast as we possibly can.
And wouldn't that be lovely if that was
really the way out?
So anyways,
um,
and now for that,
so let's,
let's try some questions here.
So
any advice on effectively implementing
what I learned into my life?
I resonate with 12 rules so much when
reading,
but struggle to remember it in my day to
day life.
Well,
you're not alone.
Not with Sam.
You're not alone in that,
Sam.
I mean,
first of all,
you've got to figure out what your
timeframe is.
You know,
um,
one of the truisms of clinical
psychology is that slow and incremental
improvement is first of all,
normative in the best possible way,
in the most optimistic situation,
but also very powerful.
And so of course you struggled to
remember it in your day to day life
because life is difficult and it's
harder to do things the not to do them.
And it's harder to do them well than to
do them badly,
you know,
and it's easy to sit around and be
hopeless.
I don't mean it's emotionally easy
because it's not,
but it's procedural,
easy to be useless and to fall back into
your old habits and to not discipline
yourself.
And it's,
it's a matter of continual practice,
slow continual practice.
And I think a good example of that is
something like weightlifting.
You know,
if you start a weightlifting program,
which I would recommend by the way,
because it,
it's tremendously advantageous
physically and cognitively,
you're not going to really see results
for a number of weeks and then the
results are rather slow.
But you can get pretty decent results
over a six month period and absolutely
stellar results over a couple of years.
And so you have to make sure your
timeframe is right and not to be too
hard on yourself.
And I did mention the future authoring
program,
um,
earlier.
And one of the things I would recommend
too is if you're having a hard time
implementing your,
your decision,
say you're ethical decisions that you
spend a bit more time thinking them
through and writing them down in the
future authoring program is really
helpful thought.
That's why we designed it and so get
your goal straight and continue to
practice every day and if you're not
succeeding then make your goals slightly
smaller.
You want to,
you want to make your goals large enough
so that they challenge you but small
enough so that you have a reasonable
probability of succeeding at them on a
day to day basis and then you have to
also understand that if you fail on a
given day,
I could,
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think,
oh my God,
now I've screwed it up.
I've not quitting anymore.
You smoke a whole pack of cigarettes.
It's like,
well there's a couple of mistakes there
and one is,
well,
just because you had a cigarette doesn't
mean you failed.
It just means that you had a cigarette,
you can start stopping again the next
day.
And the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that.
And so you've gotta be realistically
humble.
You've got to be ambitious enough in
your goals so that you're pursuing
something that you regard as truly
meaningful and worthwhile.
You know,
and maybe you can judge that to some
degree.
If you think about someone you love
attempting the same thing and think
about how you would feel if they managed
it.
And if you would feel good,
then that's probably a good,
um,
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself?
You,
so you want your goals to be of
sufficient nobility so that you can live
with yourself properly if you're
pursuing them,
but you want them to be small enough so
that you have a reasonable probability
of implementing them.
And if your implementation,
okay,
that's good.
You can start again.
Maybe
we're back.
Yeah.
Okay guys.
Well,
that was interesting.
The software that I use on my camera
crashed.
And then when I reopened it,
it told me I hadn't purchased it and
wanted me to reenter the serial number,
which is quite the interesting
experience.
So,
so I'm just getting my questions back
up.
Um,
this three quarter person that you see
here is Julian,
who's,
you know,
reasonably helpful about these sorts of
things now.
And then
I've Al,
I've almost actually learned how to do
this.
I tell you,
you do get slower technologically as you
get older.
It's kind of annoying or maybe get just
fed up with it more.
It's hard to tell.
I think you probably stupider and less
patient and so then you justify your
less pay your stupidity by just assuming
that you're less patient.
So,
okay.
Anyways,
um,
we're back.
Thanks Julian.
Okay.
So Paul Maloney says,
you mentioned analyzing one of your
wife's dreams that left you feeling
hopeful that will emerge from this
chaos.
Okay.
Do you still feel this way?
Any new signs?
Well,
who knows,
right?
Because
because the future is complicated and no
one's a profit.
I don't know what to think.
I think this,
I guess I already mentioned earlier in
this q and a that on a global level
there is all sorts of reasons for real
optimism as far as I'm concerned.
There's reasons for pessimism as well,
but there's reasons for real optimism
and what,
look,
it looks to me like what's happening is
that this spread of
the western free market individualists
ethos around the world is producing a
substantive increment in wealth,
a substantive decrease in poverty.
And the consequence of that decrease in
poverty is also in places like China,
which by the way,
China is reforesting.
So that's pretty interesting.
China's now rich enough so that it can
afford to reforest.
So there's more forest in China than
there was in 1990 which is quite a
remarkable thing.
Anyways,
my point is,
is that on the global scale,
things appeared to be very positive
and the,
but then in the West we seem to be
suffering from a crisis of confidence
and that's destabilizing us and making
us act foolishly.
And I don't know how much of a threat
that is to the integrity of our
political system.
Um,
and I'm so much in the middle of this
let's say,
um,
personally that it's hard for me to have
a clear head about it.
Now I'm very optimistic about a variety
of things that I see.
I'm very optimistic,
for example,
about the fact that so many people have
are coming out to these long form
lectures and paying attention to high
complexity,
educational and political material on
Youtube.
There's a real hunger for that.
And I,
as I said before,
the lecture tour that I'm on has been
extremely positive.
Um,
it's really something to see all these
thousands of people come out to
concentrate on getting their lives
together.
And I do believe that that's why people
are coming out.
And then,
you know,
I think,
I don't remember if I did a q and a
since I did the discussions with Sam
Harris,
but,
um,
I did for discussions with him for
debates,
let's say each of which was about two
hours long,
two in Vancouver,
one in Dublin and one in London,
UK.
And there were about 3000 people at each
of the Vancouver events,
8,500 people in Dublin.
And something approximating 6,500 in
London.
And the audience was very attentive for
the two hour stretch for all four
discussions.
And so I do see the,
I see more intelligence in the general
population say then I think we presumed
was there and more hunger for serious
discussion.
And I'm hoping that people who are clear
headed and sensible can push back the
idiot collectivist radicals on the left
and on the right.
We'll see.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm hopeful because I think that people
are remarkable creatures despite their
limitations and the absurdity of our
existence and our proclivity toward
malevolence.
I think that
w
we can,
whatever constitutes our essence is
capable of transcending that.
And I think that people know that.
And I think the more people that realize
that consciously and start to implement
it,
the better off we'll be.
And so nested inside my extreme
pessimism about the structure of life
and the frailty of human character is an
acceptable optimism,
exceptional optimism about our
potential.
So we'll see.
But I would also say to all of you that
are listening,
you know,
it is my firm belief that each of us
have a responsibility to set the world
right in the manner that we are able to
end.
That that is a fundamental,
that's a fundamental import.
I really believe in some sense it's of
cosmic import in the same way that
consciousness itself is of cosmic import
and consciousness reflects being itself.
And so,
and I do believe that we have the
ability and the responsibility to bring
new creation into being and that our
ethical decisions help us,
that our ethical decisions,
that the value of that new being is
dependent directly on the ethical
decisions that each of us make.
And I think we can realize that even
though it's a frightening thing to
realize,
Marcus Perry asks,
you said,
the narrow bandwidth of TV has made us
think we are stupider than we are.
We'll internet center censorship lead to
the same problem once TV is supplanted.
Well,
God,
another incredibly complicated question.
You know,
whenever I think about censorship,
I actually talked to mark Zuckerberg
awhile back and we had a good
conversation,
you know,
and Zuckerberg,
who I think is a very straightforward
person as far as I could tell,
um,
is optimistic about facebook and does
see it as a platform whose primary goal
is to connect people and mostly at the
personal level,
although they've,
facebook has made forays into news
provision and that's complicated their
corporate vision.
Now I am not a pro censorship character.
I do not like hate speech legislation
and I am absolutely opposed to compelled
speech legislation of the sort that's
been introduced into Canada.
I think it's a violation of the
principle of free speech and free
thought.
And I think it's exceptionally
dangerous.
But having said that,
you know,
nothing is ever simple and that's part
of the reason that things are so
annoying politically.
So,
you know,
one of the things that apple and
facebook and so forth,
those,
the large social media platforms had to
contend with say,
was the attempts by organizations like
isis to use their platforms for
recruitment.
Now,
let's say that I'm a free speech
absolutist,
which isn't exactly true because I
realize that there are the constraints
that he evolved in some sense naturally
in the English common law system on free
speech and that they're necessary.
You can't libel someone,
you can't outright lie about someone,
you can't slandered them,
you can't counsel them to criminal
conduct,
et Cetera.
There are restrictions on free speech
well,
but I think those restrictions should be
minimal.
Well,
let's say that one of the restrictions
you assume should be placed on free
speech is that those that you are at war
with are not allowed to use your
platform to recruit,
which doesn't seem to be an unreasonable
proposition and is perhaps even the sort
of thing and a conservative or a
libertarian,
much less a liberal or a left winger
might get behind.
Well then that means that you've defined
already a framework in which is that
censorship and or maybe I'm not thinking
this through clearly,
but is that censorship?
It certainly self protection.
Well then having established the
principle that a certain amount of Mod,
what would you call,
monitoring of the use of your platform
is necessary.
Where do you stop and answer is
it's complicated.
Um,
I think that what facebook,
etc. Did with Alex Jones was a big
mistake.
I think that was because,
well,
it wasn't just Alex Jones that was
punished,
let's say it was all the people that
were watching him and not everybody that
was watching him was an avid follower of
him.
Um,
some people were just watching him to
see what the hell he was doing and what
he was up to.
And that's necessary,
but you don't just sensor the one
person,
you censor everybody that's paying
attention to them.
And then you make him a martyr and you
persecute someone who's paranoid,
which all that does is validate his
conspiracy theories is conspiratorial
theories and the conspiratorial theories
of his followers.
Um,
I guess one of the things I've really
been wondering is if the wild and woolly
reality of facebook and Youtube and
twitter are actually sustainable in a
corporate environment or if the radical
freedom that was associated with those
technologies was only something that was
possible,
when in some sense,
all of that material provision,
all the provision of that material was
outside the standard legal framework
because it was too new to regulate.
You know,
I can't tell,
I don't know if corporations can manage
something like youtube or twitter or
facebook for that matter because their
internal conservatism and there,
and I mean that in the,
in the temperamental sense,
their unwillingness to take risk is,
is,
is what I mean in that particular case
is liable to make it impossible for them
to be neutral purveyors of information,
some of which is going to be extremely
radical.
So
well,
so there's,
I have no conclusions to offer there.
I,
and I guess I'm glad in some sense that
these complicated,
these particular complicated problems
aren't mine to solve.
I certainly think that the production of
automated sensors is a very,
very bad idea.
But I'm also someone who's
constitutionally opposed to such things
as closed circuit TV monitor,
monitoring of the general public as
well.
And,
and cameras that,
that watch people at stoplights and any
automated system that that enforces the
law or the or what's hypothetically the
law to me is to be regarded with deep,
deep suspicion.
So,
okay.
That's that much of my early work deals
with alcoholism.
Yes.
And with Ann at the biological level,
that's what I did my phd thesis on and
much of my early published papers where
I learned brain function because alcohol
affects every part of the brain.
So I had learned a lot about the brain.
What prompted my interest in that area.
And you're a parent shift,
two issues clustered around personality.
While I was always interested in
motivation for drug and alcohol abuse,
you know what it was that drove people
to use drugs of,
of,
of abuse,
let's say.
And,
um,
I got the opportunity to study at Miguel
under Dr Robert Peel,
who was an excellent supervisor and he
was deeply involved with,
um,
drug and alcohol abuse research,
looking at motivation for alcoholism.
And he offered me a position in his lab
and,
and that was what he was working on.
And I thought,
well,
that was one of my cardinal interests,
although perhaps not my,
my fundamental interest,
which even at that point had to do with
motivation for totalitarianism and the
commission of a trustee in the service
of,
of group belief.
But I thought,
well,
it's a broad topic and I could learn a
lot about biology and neurobiology as a
consequence of working on something that
was so biological.
So my,
my early work in psychology was
extremely biologically oriented and it
was unbelievably useful.
I learned a lot from the animal
experimentalists in particular,
people like Jeffrey Gray and later Jaak
Panksepp.
Um,
I have a reading list at Jordan B.
Peterson Dotcom that outlines some of
those emotional,
so those books on emotional
neuroscience.
Um,
what was my,
why did I shift?
While there was a variety of reasons.
One was that the National Institute of
Alcohol Abuse and alcoholism and I aaa,
which funded grant research in the
United States essentially made the
corner of research I was doing with
Robert Peale.
Impossible.
And it's part of the consequence.
I think this is one of the things that
the universities are doing so terribly
wrong,
is the ethics committees made our
research impossible both to fund and to
implement.
So here's why.
So we were bringing people into the lab.
So here's who we pick for subjects.
If you are going to be a subject in one
of our experiments,
you had to be a young man and you had to
have an alcoholic father and an
alcoholic grandfather,
and at least one other first or second
degree male alcoholic relative.
Hmm.
Well I hope I'm back again.
You know what my software updated and
obviously the update has a bug,
so that's rather annoying.
Okay.
Pauly g's for that once again.
Yeah.
So back to the alcoholism discussion.
Um,
okay,
where was I?
Oh yes.
So we would get these subjects.
I mentioned who they were,
they were young men who weren't
alcoholic,
but who drank socially,
who had an alcoholic father,
an alcoholic grandfather,
and at least one other male alcoholic
relative.
Now why did we pick subjects like that?
Well,
we knew alcoholism ran in families and
we couldn't really study its
transmission and women because if you're
a female alcoholic and you drink when
you have a child in Utero,
then the child can have fetal alcohol
syndrome and whatever abnormalities in
psychophysiological response or
psychopathology is,
might be associated with their
alcoholism can easily be masked by the
presence of fetal alcohol syndrome.
So we couldn't use women.
And besides alcoholism is a problem that
fundamentally characterized as men.
Although there are female alcoholics,
I think it's four to one,
if I remember correctly from from those
days,
it's four to one male to female.
So it was,
we know when we thought if we
concentrated on those who had the
highest probability of developing
alcoholism because of their loaded
family history that we could shed some
light on the mechanisms associated with
alcoholism and that would be useful for
men and for women.
So we studied sons of male alcoholics,
sons of multigenerational male
alcoholics.
Those were our target group,
very hard populations to fight.
We have people hired full time to do
nothing but find us research subjects
and so we did relatively small end
studies because we were lucky if we
could gather four or five subjects a
month in the Montreal urban area.
Okay.
Anyways,
we did discover a lot about alcoholism.
We discovered for example,
that if people with this
multigenerational history,
a substantial proportion of them,
if they drank enough alcohol to move
their blood level up above 0.08 which is
legal intoxication level,
and if they did that relatively short
period of time,
then their heart rate would increase
above.
I think the average was about 12 beats
per minute compared to the standard
control of of zero zero or one or two.
It was is very low.
And so,
and then we did figure out over time,
our whole team that that seemed to be a
consequence of susceptibility to
alcohol's effect on opioid production in
the brain and secondary,
uh,
or opioid effects on dopamine,
which is both opiates and dopamine are
primarily primary reward chemicals.
So it looked to us like people with
multigenerational family histories of
alcoholism got an opiate response from
alcohol.
So,
but we had to get people drunk in order
to find this response.
And it turned out that 0.08,
which was the legal limit at that time
for driving was approximately the place
where we,
the psychophysiological effects and also
saw fairly pronounced cognitive and
motor effects of alcohol because we also
studied that.
So now to bring it,
we bring people into the lab and we'd
give them three large shots of alcohol
that they consumed in 10 minutes.
We use laboratory alcohol,
which was I think 95% pure alcohol,
usually put it in orange juice.
Um,
and so people would be,
you know,
reasonably intoxicated.
And then we would let them sober up
until they were at 0.04,
which is half legal intoxication,
which we thought was useful.
And then we put them into cabin and
they'd go home and we,
you know,
we had our odd mishap now and then
someone would throw up and that was,
well I'm at least getting better at
fixing it when it screws up now.
So,
um,
you know,
and in anyways now and then we would
have somebody who would be become ill in
the lab and that was always unpleasant.
But then we,
we'd also let people sober up and it
actually takes quite a long time to go
from point a to 0.04,
especially if you're a big guy cause
your,
your dose of El Calls proportionate to
your body weight.
And so we used to have people wait in
the lab for a couple of hours,
you know,
and they were not very happy necessarily
about having to wait before we paid them
and so forth.
And,
and,
and if we didn't treat them
extraordinarily well,
which we tried to do,
then of course they were much less
likely to come back and participate in
another study.
And since it was very difficult to get
research subjects,
then we wanted to treat them very well
apart from the fact that we would have
done that anyways.
But then,
and I aaa said,
well,
you can't let your research subjects go
home until they have a blood alcohol
level of point.
Oh two was like,
we would have had to have people in our
lab,
you know,
sobering up for
okay,
for six to eight hours.
This keeps happening.
I'm very sorry about this,
everyone.
Um,
I don't know what to say about it except
that that's a consequence of software
updates,
I suppose.
Um,
anyways,
so that made it impossible because we
just couldn't keep people in the lab for
that long.
All it did was annoyed them to death and
then they hated us and they,
you know,
people would get quite irritable and
upset and no bloody wonder.
So then also,
and I aaa decided that half our subjects
had to be women or we couldn't get
funding.
Well now our subjects couldn't be women.
It was impossible to do the kind of
research that we were doing with women
for the reasons that I just outlined.
Well,
first of all,
um,
alcoholism doesn't affect women as much
as it affects men.
Depression and anxiety tend to affect
women more and it's perfectly reasonable
to study those things.
But that isn't what we were doing.
And uh,
and then we couldn't do
multigenerational studies for genetic
predisposition with women because of the
fetal alcohol syndrome problem.
And you know,
this was something,
I think this came in under Clintons,
this re requirement for absolute gender
equality in,
in subject selection.
And they didn't give a damn if that
meant that there were certain kinds of
research that just couldn't be done
anymore.
And so I had to stop doing it and no
one's really doing that kind of research
anymore because it's just too difficult.
It's like it was always a pain because
it was really hard to get the subjects
and then you had to get people quite
intoxicated and then you had to deal
with them when they were drunk and you
had to do your psychophysiological
recording and all that sort of thing.
And then they had to sober up and you
know,
it was complicated.
Clinical research is unbelievably,
unbelievably complicated and difficult.
And then yeah,
I'd like to more restrictions to it and
people just go,
oh,
okay,
well we,
I guess we won't study the
psychophysiological consequences of
alcohol anymore or so people would use
low doses,
you know,
and want to get their subject's blood
alcohol level up to like 0.02 or
[inaudible] three.
But that's completely irrelevant because
alcohol doesn't have much of a
physiological effect at those low doses.
And so,
well this is one of the things that made
me absolutely despise ethics committees.
And I believe that the proliferation of
ethics committees is one of the reasons
that university research human research
is,
is doing badly.
Psychological research is doing badly.
There's a variety of reasons,
but that's certainly one of them.
So I was interested,
sorry this is a very long answer,
but I was interested in personality as
well.
You know,
because I was a clinical psychologist
and I had read Freud and Jung and Adler
and all the great clinicians of the 20th
century.
And when I went to Harvard,
um,
I was offered,
uh,
you know,
I,
when you're a new faculty member there's
usually a set course that they require
you to teach.
That's one of the core courses.
And then you have some freedom with your
other courses.
And so I said I'd teach personality and
then I got more and more and we were
looking at personality models with the
alcoholism research too.
At that point,
the big five was starting to establish
itself.
And I wasn't much of an admirer of the
big five because I like,
while I like theories as well as
empirical research.
And I thought the big five,
while there was just no theory at all,
it was just brute force empiricism,
but well,
but you know,
that data eventually became convincing.
And as I got more and more interested
in,
um,
in personality,
I got more and more interested in the
use of personality and other
psychometric technologies to predict
things like academic and creative
success.
You see it at mcgill,
my bob and I and a variety of other
people were using,
um,
psychological tests of various sorts to
predict things like alcoholism and
antisocial personality.
So we could use the big five and
neuropsychological tests,
tests of Dorsolateral prefrontal
function,
at least in principle,
to predict to some degree who might be
susceptible to the development of anti
social personality.
And then when I went to Harvard,
I thought,
well,
hey,
maybe we could use those tests to
predict who was going to be good at
things as well as who was going to be
bad.
You know,
the people who are creative are the,
who were,
um,
academically,
outstanding or people who did well as
managers and administrators and
corporations might do well on
personality tests.
And,
and neuropsychological tests that assess
dorsolateral prefrontal functions,
that's higher order cognition.
So we started to put together test
batteries that,
um,
assessed that and that was fascinating
research.
I did that with Daniel Higgins,
who's the partner,
my partner in the development of the
self authoring program and understand
myself that things that he's labored for
20 years on before they really became
successful.
Um,
and he wrote a bang up thesis.
I think it was the best thing ever
written on this,
on the topic of intelligence.
And,
and launched that he started working on
in,
in 1993,
which is about the same time that the
bell curve came out.
And so his research actually became row
relatively politically contentious,
even though all we were trying to do was
trying to determine what attributes
predicted success among creative people
and among managers and administrators
and in it and in academia and so forth,
pure empirical research.
But it became real,
very rapidly politicized anyways.
So I just got more and more interested
in psychometrics,
partly because I realized way back when
in 1993 that almost nothing that's
psychologists measured was actually
real.
And so we were interested in what was
And Daniel is an engineer and trained at
Mit.
And so he was very,
very method method,
a methodical person.
And he didn't like to move ahead with
his research at all unless he had nailed
absolutely everything down in a way that
only an engineer and a software coder
would.
And so we started working on personality
models and I've been doing that and
concentrating on that more specifically
ever since,
as well as writing the more theoretical
material that was associated say with 12
rules for life in maps of meaning.
So.
Okay.
So that's that answer.
Are you aware of any of your critics?
Are you aware of any critics of your
work who are deep and credible?
Well,
of course not.
Um,
someone who had a minimum had read maps
of meaning.
Well,
it's a complicated question.
Um,
you know,
I've never read a critic of young who
actually understood what you and was
talking about.
And I actually knew a number of
scientists including Jaak Panksepp who
wrote an affect of neuroscience,
which is a great book,
who is a real admirer of young and,
and the psychoanalysts.
I mean,
um,
Panksepp was very interested,
neuro psycho analysis and most of the
people,
many of the people who are interested in
the F in the neuroscience of emotion,
we're also very interested in the
psychoanalytic types.
Most of the people who criticize young
don't have a clue what he was talking
about.
And it's not surprising cause he's very
difficult.
No,
I haven't come across a credible critic
of maps of meaning.
And I think,
and I don't know,
I mean that may also be because,
you know,
until I became notorious,
let's say over the last couple of years,
it
was,
it influential.
It did pretty well.
The book did pretty well for a,
an academic work.
It was no massive seller,
although it's hit the best seller list
now on the,
in the audio version,
which I think is pretty amusing.
And that's The New York Times bestseller
list,
given that they wouldn't list 12 rules
for life.
Um,
okay.
So,
I don't know if the lack of criticism is
a consequence of its lack of influence
or
it's difficulty.
I've had social psychologists talk to me
a little bit about the ideas of maps of
meaning.
And I tried to talk to them,
especially the people that are
interested in such things as terror
management.
But,
um,
they're,
they usually don't know the
neuropsychology and they don't know the
mythology.
And there are very few people who are
versed in the world of neuropsychology
and in the world of mythology
simultaneously.
And I'm drawing these parallels,
you know,
like,
um,
and they're very complicated parallels.
So I made the assumption,
see,
I studied these Russian
neuropsychologists,
vinegar Dova and Sokolov who were
students of Alexander Luria brilliant
students,
and they discovered this phenomena
called the orienting reflex,
which I wrote a lot about in maps of
meaning.
And the orienting reflex is your
automatic response to what is unknown.
And you have a very deep automatic
response to what is unknown.
And that really means that the unknown
is a conceptual category.
And it was my proposition developed in
maps of meaning that the unknown is a
fundamental cognitive category or maybe
even a fundamental category of reality
depending on how you define reality.
Like I'm defining reality
phenomenologically as experienced,
um,
but as experienced universally and has
experienced biologically by animals and
by human beings,
um,
the unknown is something like unexplored
territory and it's reasonable to assume
that there's a fundamental distinction
even neurologically between the patterns
of action that are obtained in
territories that you've thoroughly
explored and the pattern of action
that's necessary when you step outside
the domain that you're familiar with,
where your reaction as a prey animal or
perhaps as a Predator has to become
paramount.
And so the fundamental proposition in
maps of meaning is something like the
domain of the unknown that's reflexively
responded to with the orienting reflex,
which is a very,
very fundamental reflex and basic to the
entire process of learning itself is
reflected in our mythological
representations.
And I think that that is a absolutely.
Okay.
Um,
if that's true,
then it's a profound realization.
I wouldn't exactly say discovery because
I don't know if you bring two
literatures together that have never
been conjoined,
if that constitutes of discovery.
But I've certainly never found anyone
who was able.
Okay.
Suggest to me any reason why I should
assume that that hypothesis is
incorrect.
You know what,
I've had pretty damn bright graduate
students and they've gone off to be
credible professors and most of them
have maintained that viewpoint.
And I think calling the youngest
probably foremost among them.
So,
mmm.
You know,
it would be nice actually,
if,
if I could encounter critics of maps of
meaning who were credible because I'm
sure there's some things in it that I
wrote that were wrong.
Um,
and I don't know what they are.
I mean,
I'd be thinking about the damn book
since 1982 and I'd been thinking about a
lot in my work in 12 rules for life is
an extension of what I did in maps of
meaning,
but I can't see holes in it and nothing
I've learned since then.
And that might be a consequence of my
own stupidity.
But a narrow mindedness is,
I haven't seen any reason to radically
revise the propositions that I put forth
in maps of meaning.
I think they're credible.
I think the idea that,
and I think there's actually more
evidence now that the propositions were
correct then there were,
when I wrote the book originally,
the idea for example,
that our hemispheres are specialized one
for action in the domain of the known
and the other for action in the domain
of the unknown.
I think that's well supported by the
work of um,
what's his name?
No other student of Lyria,
Greenberg,
um,
elk,
Conan Goldberg,
Elkhorn and Goldberg.
Um,
and Rama Shondra and as well,
and a neuro,
uh,
a physician who's well versed in
neuroscience has,
has,
has a theory that's quite similar.
Um,
so no,
I don't think maps of meaning has been
subject to proper critical evaluation.
So,
and then with regards to critics of my,
of 12 rules for life,
well,
most of the time they don't criticize
what I say.
They criticized there,
what would you call it?
Ideologically motivated,
pathological oversimplification of who
they wish I was.
So they didn't have to take anything I
said seriously.
And those people don't constitute
critics.
They constitute,
yeah,
they constitute the chattering puppets
of,
of the,
of a certain form of ideological
possession.
Wesley Yang reported that you met with
Tech Titans,
Marc Andreessen and Peter Teal,
both of whom advocate decentralized
education.
Can you share anything about this?
Um,
I dunno if I can share anything
interesting.
I mean I enjoyed the meeting mark and
Peter.
I met mark several times.
Um,
I've only met Peter Wants,
although I've spent some time with Eric
Weinstein who works with Peter,
you know,
Peter is Libertarian oriented.
Um,
and so,
okay.
He,
he,
he shares concerns about the potential
totalitarian function of Internet
technology and manifesting itself well
in,
in the constant monitoring of our
behavior and also in,
in the emergent censorship.
Let's say Marc Andreessen,
well mark's a smart guy and he knows a
lot of other smart guys and we spent a
lot of time talking about the
possibility of online education and,
and,
but there isn't anything really exciting
I can report about that.
I mean they were all preliminary
discussions of a sort to see if we could
get long and if we could talk and so far
we've been able to,
I am making a hair fair bit of headway
with this university project,
although we don't really conceptualize
it as a university project anymore.
We're conceptualizing it as an adaptive
learning system and we're trying to use
it to index people's no index knowledge
on the web funnel money to creative
producers of educational content,
allow people to test their knowledge no
matter how it's generated and to
accredit people properly and we'll
release,
release more information about that in
the upcoming months as we move closer
and closer to a functional prototype.
The plan at the moment,
I've talked to lots of people like
Andrea said and teal who who are very
interested in technology and education
who also are very well capitalized and
have had the opportunity multiple times
to pull in investors into this
educational project.
But I haven't done that partly because
weirdly enough,
you know,
you think money is a solution to a
problem,
but it's also,
it's often a problem in and of itself.
And if I generated several million
dollars,
let's say,
to fund this educational
endeavor,
then I would not only have to worry
about how to design the educational
system,
but then I'd have to worry about how to
spend that money and shepherd that money
intelligently.
And that's actually a huge
administrative problem of sufficient
magnitude to stop you from doing any
creative thinking at all.
So what we're doing instead is I'm
funding the university project at the
moment or the online education project
as a consequence of my patriot and
funding.
Fix that in about five seconds this
time.
So,
um,
I'm funding that from my patrion
donations in our,
I like that model better.
The only problem is,
is that I would like to offer the people
that I have his employees a certain
amount of financial stability.
And so,
and you know,
it isn't obvious to me how stable the
Patriot on funding is,
although it's been very stable so far,
but you know,
who knows how that will work out.
So I think what we're going to do is to
crowdfund in October or November once we
have a minimal viable product.
And I,
I think I'd rather do that than raise
money privately anyways because I don't
want this project to be beholden to
anyone.
And I wanted to maintain control over
its direction with a small group of
programmers.
You know,
it's often a small group of people who
are working tightly together that solve
very complicated problems.
And that's certainly been the case with
working,
say with Daniel Higgins and Robert Peel
on the self authoring programs and so
forth.
Small team.
We've,
we've thought about going the venture
capital route and expanding and trying
to make a big business out of it.
But our sense was more that it,
and maybe we were wrong about this,
but that was better to go directly after
customers and to build the business
incrementally and to test it along each
step and not to get enticed by the
possibility of Unicorn level money.
And so,
um,
anyways,
that's the,
that's the situation there.
And I've got three really bright people
working on this,
um,
open educational platform and it's
really quite exciting.
And I would say we're,
we're well ahead of schedule from where
I thought we would be.
So that's pretty cool.
Have you spoken to Nassim to lab
following your brief twitter exchange?
Would love to hear a conversation with
the two of you?
I'd like to talk to him too because he's
very,
very smart.
He's a,
he's touchy though and so I have some
apprehension about that.
I've,
I've talked to lots of touchy people
over the last couple of years and I'm a
bit apprehensive about it,
but I would like to do that.
There's a lot of people I'd like to talk
to.
He's one of them in and you know,
it's,
I'm having a hard time setting up those
conversations at the moment because I'm
doing so much touring.
I am talking again to Jonathan Heit
though in the near future and I think
probably to Steven pinker as well.
And by the way,
for those of you who are wondering,
um,
I am going to release the,
and so is Sam.
We're going to release the videos from
the Sam Harris Peterson debates.
Um,
I'll put them on my youtube channel.
Sam,
we'll put them on his will,
make them into podcasts as well.
I'm going to just release the first one
on September 1st and uh,
and everyone will have access to it.
Um,
it's taken us a while to figure out
exactly how to do this,
partly because Travis Pangbourne who
hosted the events,
wanted to raise some money with the
videos,
um,
at least in part to help offset the
costs that he incurred for those events,
which were very expensive,
believe it or not,
and difficult to generate a profit for
from on his end.
Um,
and also he wants to translate the
material that he already has into
multiple languages.
So we agreed to let him when we had to
make a three way agreement for this,
you know,
because Sam was involved and I was
involved in,
so it was paying burn and so,
and we didn't know how the events would
go,
you know,
so we weren't actually that concerned
with the damn videos to begin with
because we take,
uh,
we,
we'd take an,
uh,
a risk.
I'm not complaining about this by the
way,
like I'm not complaining about taking a
risk,
but we didn't.
Salmon,
I hadn't even met,
you know,
we didn't know if you're going to have
conversations that were worthwhile.
We didn't know if anybody would show up
for the events.
And so we were way more concerned about
whether or not we'd get a crowd of any
sort,
whether the events would be successful
and whether we could actually talk then
what we would do with the videos if the,
or even if there would be videos if the
events were successful.
And so it turned out that we couldn't
talk and we did have useful discussions.
At least we thought so.
And the audiences responded very well
and there was large crowds and so it was
successful.
So then it turned out that the videos
were worthwhile,
but we hadn't discussed who had control
over the videos or who was going to edit
them or any of those things.
And we had to do that post hoc after the
fact,
which isn't the best way of doing it.
And then it took travis awhile to
assemble a team to do the actual
editing.
And so that was our compromise.
And you know,
it would've been better if we could have
released the videos and all of that
immediately after the talks.
But you know,
when you're doing something new and you
don't know exactly what you're doing,
you're not going to do it perfectly.
And so we didn't do that perfectly,
but the events were good.
And I enjoyed talking to Sam and I
learned a lot from the discussion.
I really had to sharpen my thinking.
I really figured out something,
you know,
I figured out that I think the
fundamental issue here is how you take
the infinite world of facts that
presents itself to you,
independent of the value of those facts.
So value neutral facts.
And they have to be filtered to a single
point,
like a single point of perception
because you have to point your eyes at
one thing and your attention at one
thing and a single point of action.
And so there's a tremendous reducing of
the world of fact to the extraordinarily
simple and targeted rule of Vail or
world of value and your,
your brain is the instrument that does
that reducing and it's sort of,
it's in keeping with Elvis Huxley's
suppositions about and that,
and they were motivated by Henri
Bergson,
the idea that the brain was a reducing
valve and that what psychedelic
experience did was open the doors of
perception.
Something William Blake also talked
about.
The brain seems to be in some sense the
part of the structure that reduces the
infinite complexity of the world of
facts to the finite and single point
domain of world of values.
And that's partly neurologically
instantiated and partly sociologically
instantiated as we come to a negotiated
agreement about what constitutes value,
just like we do about what constitutes
value economically.
And so the structure that reduces facts
to values is a reducing structure that's
similar caneously in Stan,
Shelia instantiated neurologically and
sociologically.
And I understand that a lot more clearly
because I had these discussions with Sam
and I'm writing a lot about that in this
next book,
which is,
it's a followup.
I s I suspect that's the plan at the
moment to 12 rules for life because I
had written originally 40 rules,
so I have more to go.
I've written about half the new book and
I spent a lot of time writing about,
at least in part what I had to become
clearer about as a consequence of my
discussions with Harris.
And so I took a look at the videos and
I,
I think the debates were productive and,
and their audiences seem to find them.
So,
and certainly salmon.
I did,
I really enjoyed meeting him.
We got along quite well.
He has much better sense of humor than I
presumed from listening.
Well,
from the two podcasts we did.
Of course,
I wasn't in great humor when I did those
either.
Um,
and you know,
I also think that I'm also,
what would you say I'm a fan of Sam's
motivation?
Uh,
or at least as far as I could determine
it.
I mean he wants to ground the world of
value in something that isn't merely
arbitrary revelation.
And Fair enough,
man,
that's a good,
that's a good aim to ground ethics in
something that it's solid.
Um,
and,
and not just arbitrary opinion,
but I think that the devil's in the
details.
And so that's basically what we
discussed.
So,
um,
okay.
How do you reconcile studies that show
genetic superseding environment in life
outcomes with your own experience
conducting successful psychotherapy?
Yeah.
Well,
I'll tell you one thing,
man,
that I've really come to realize more
and more in the last three or four
years.
Partly I would say from dealing with my
own health problems to some degree,
but also watching the health problems
that my daughter had.
Um,
I think a lot of what we think of as
mental illness is physical illness.
It's a lot more than we think even,
but,
and I think that that is reflected in
the genetic studies.
Um,
but I also think,
I also still think that that doesn't
eliminate the rule of learning.
You know,
um,
people obviously learn and they can
learn better or worse and they learn
better when they voluntary voluntarily
approach things that are frightening and
threatening and they challenged
themselves.
And so,
um,
it's made me more humble,
I would say in some sense both as a
person and as a psychotherapist because
I'm more attuned to the fact that the
apparently psychological difficulties
that my clients might be experiencing,
maybe a consequence of an underlying
destabilization of physical health.
I'm really unwilling to discount that.
Um,
even if what they're experiencing is
very idiosyncratic.
But it still seems to me that there is
credible evidence that exposure to,
to what you would rather avoid is
curative.
And so is the weaving together of a
coherent and a coherent map or narrative
of your experience.
I believe that those doctrines are
solid.
So,
and that's what psychotherapists do.
Essentially,
they help you get your story straight
about your past and your present and
your future.
They help you establish your point in
life.
They help you lay out a map so that you
can negotiate through the territory of
your life,
past,
present and future.
And they help you develop strategies to
deal with,
to help deal with emergent complexity
and the fear that goes along with it.
So,
um,
Michael Tom Rose House,
a very hard question.
Please comment on young Paulie's.
That's Wolfgang Paulie's.
Who knows?
Mundus hypothesis one world hypothesis
essentially.
So that,
so Michael,
Tom Ross ass,
sorry,
I got frozen there again momentarily.
Please comment on Yom [inaudible] Mundus
hypothesis.
Does this correlate with quantum theory
solutions to the hard problem?
Eg Penrose Hameroff or church or,
or C,
H R I don't know what orange or is.
I know penrose and Hameroff.
I'm not an admirer of the pen.
Penrose and Hameroff,
uh,
attempt to reduce consciousness to,
to,
um,
microtubule function,
quantum mechanics and microtubule
function.
I did my best to understand it.
I couldn't,
it seemed hollow to me.
My experience has generally been,
if I find something incomprehensible and
hollow,
it generally is.
Um,
I've read better books on consciousness,
um,
like the user illusion,
which I really liked.
That's the user illusion,
by the way.
In Jeffrey Gray wrote a good book on
consciousness as well.
Um,
the only,
and Paulie,
I'm not going to be able to answer this
question very well cause I'm starting to
get a bit worn out here.
Um,
Wolfgang and Pauli and young recognized
that,
man,
this is really a complicated problem.
I don't know if I can,
I don't know if I can answer this.
Okay,
let's try this.
God,
it's been years since I thought about
this and wrote about it.
So we'll see how I can do.
You could think about this from a
perspective of psg,
Hattie and constructivism.
So imagine that what you confront.
Yeah.
What you fundamentally in the world is
what is unknowable and what is
unknowable has an intrinsic meaning.
It's both frightening and compelling.
Simultaneously,
it activates Predator detection systems
that protect you in the way that a prey
animal is protected by freezing and
withdrawal and that sort of thing.
But it also makes you curious so that
which you do not understand,
which is something that you can
conceptualize as that which has not yet
been made.
Habitable world has an intrinsic
meaning.
Now the question is whether the
fundamental stuff of the world is that
meaningful unknown or something
material.
You can make the case that what we
recognize as material is actually a
pragmatic reconceptualization of the
meaning of the ambivalent meaning of the
unknowable.
Now I know that that's hard.
That's a hard concept,
but imagine you see,
it depends on whether or not you believe
that our descriptions of material
reality are the superordinate
descriptions of reality or whether our
conceptualization of material is
actually a form of pragmatic tool use
that's oriented towards our survival and
this is not an easy thing to sort out.
It's something that I did try to sort
out to some degree with Sam,
you know,
is do we have an objective description
of reality and his reality,
something that can be objectively
described or are we using a technology
that produces so called objective
representations to facilitate our tool
use?
And it's a hard question,
right?
Because obviously our advanced
technology,
which we use in a tool like fashion is a
consequence of our materialist science.
Which begs the question,
is the science is the fundamental
purpose of the science descriptive or
pragmatic?
Now I think I tend to think it's
pragmatic because I think our
fundamental problem is a problem of
survival.
So there's a way of looking at the world
where the fundamental reality is the
chaotic potential that gives rise to
fear and curiosity.
And that's how your nervous system
response by the way,
and see that's interesting to me because
I would say,
well it's a truism of evolutionary
biology that what your nervous system is
adapted to what you're adapted to as a
consequence of view three and a half
billion years of evolution is reality.
And that there's no other real way of
defining it.
And so the way your brain construes
reality is as if what you're confronting
is an indeterminant chaotic potential
that first generates something like
apprehension,
fear and curiosity.
Secondarily,
the apprehension to freeze you so that
you don't get eaten or destroyed and the
curiosity to allow you to engage with
what's known.
And to transform it into habitable
territory,
which in large part consists of tools.
Now the Munis Mundus that Paulie and
young talked about seems to me to be
associated with this idea of that
chaotic potential.
And I think that's related to the
physicist wheeler's proposition,
that the fundamental reality of the
world is information rather than
material.
That material is a secondary,
what would you call it?
It's a secondary manifestation of
information.
And I think that what we confront in the
world,
see,
I don't think we're driven by the past
and or determined by the president.
I think what we do is we apprehend the
potential of the future,
that chaotic potential of the future.
And,
and I think that that's associated with
a Tohu wa Bohu,
which is the chaotic potential that God
confronted with the logos at the
beginning of the,
of time in Genesis.
I think the genesis story is a
reflection of that fundamental truth.
And I think that that capability
characterizes us.
And so the onus Mundus is the
informational substrate that constitutes
the world before it's divided into
psyche.
So that would be spirit.
That'd be human spirit and consciousness
and material.
So there's something underneath that.
And this is what young and Paulie we're
driving out in my understanding,
there's something underneath that which
is the pre division unity of reality.
And that's something like the Tohu wa
Bohu or the tail,
which is etymologically cognate by the
way,
with the word Tiamat.
And Tiamat is the goddess that the
message Damien Creator,
God Marduk confronted and cut into
pieces and made the world from.
So that's all outlined in maps of
meaning,
although not so much the onus Mundus
hypothesis.
You know,
and I haven't thought about that for a
while.
I wrote about it,
but these were in papers I never
published because they were too damn
complicated.
And I tried to publish them a couple of
times with people.
Okay.
But people didn't understand what I was
talking about and you know,
I hadn't even thought about,
oh man.
Okay,
well,
okay,
here's a weird thing.
All right,
well,
the rate at which my camera equipment is
crashing seems to be accelerating.
So it appears that discussion of the
onus Mundus is
irritating the structure of reality in
some manner.
Anyways,
let's get back to it for a minute.
So this is a different way of
conceptualizing the world.
I think it's a phenomenological
perspective,
so,
and I don't know what to make of it.
So think about it this way.
So it looks like your left hemisphere is
specialized for operation in territory
that you understand.
So it's specialized for operation in
those places where behavioral patterns
have been made habitual and explicit,
whereas the right hemisphere is
specialized for response to chaos itself
to the unknown.
And what that implies is that the
division that's expressed,
for example in the in Yang symbol,
which is essentially chaos and order is
actually actually represents something
fundamental about the structure of
reality.
Now you might say,
well only the structure of reality in so
far as biological organisms
conceptualize it,
but I don't know if we can talk about
the structure of reality outside the
conceptions of biological organisms.
Like if you're a strict believer in
objective material reality in that
transcended existence of strict material
reality,
then you might say,
well,
you,
of course you could talk about it
because strict material reality exists
in the absence of biology and
consciousness,
but it isn't so obvious to me that
material reality does exist in the
absence of consciousness because I can't
conceptualize what existence would mean
in the absence of consciousness.
Like is there time?
Is their duration,
is their size?
All of these things are relative.
In some sense.
All of these things presuppose a
conscious observer even in the
materialist description.
So it looks to me like what reality is
is this newness Mundus that union Paulie
we're pointing to,
it's chaotic potential.
Now,
I also think that we treat each other
that way.
So if I'm treating you properly,
then I treat you as if you're a moral
agent who is actively engaged in the
transformation of the chaotic potential
that manifest itself as the dawning of
the future,
and that attracts your attention.
I treat you as if you're an act of moral
engage,
active moral agent,
engaged in making the moral decisions
that determine how that potential is
going to manifest itself.
And if I don't treat you that way,
then I'm patronizing.
I don't give you your full,
I don't grant you your full stature as
an,
as a a sovereign being.
And I impinge upon your knit at your
intrinsic value,
the same value that that allows you to
claim,
um,
the existence of natural rights and also
the presence I would say,
of natural responsibility.
So I treat you as if you're well,
I would say made in the image of God in
the genesis terminology that you are
part of the process that turns the Tohu
wa Bohu of should I never pronounced
properly,
um,
into habitable order.
And I think that that's the soonest
Mundus.
And I think that that's reflected in
your neurological structure.
And I think the fact that it's reflected
in your neurological structure and in
the neurological structure of animals
with this almost universal dual
hemisphere neurological structure,
which also by the way is it is something
that's necessary even in neural
networks,
which is where we got the idea for
plasticity and stability by the way,
for the in the big five aspects,
scale models in the higher order
personality factors.
Um,
I think the fact that that bifurcation
is reflected in neurology is a
reflection of the fact that it's,
it exists in reality.
Now of course,
defining reality is no simple thing.
You know,
it's,
you can think about it as an objective
materials,
but you can also think of reality as the
sum total of that which is experienced.
And those aren't the same things.
They aren't the same fundamental
presuppositions.
And I think that we've predicated our
society in so far as our society is
functional on the proposition that each
individual is a sovereign entity.
Um,
what would you say characterized by a
spark of divinity that uses the
responsible truthful word to confront
the chaos of potential and generate the
habitable order?
That is good.
I think,
I think we act out and look guys,
I'm going to call it a night eight
because obviously this has gotta be
getting somewhat annoying for you to be
constantly interrupted by these idiot
software crashes and um,
it's also approaching nine o'clock.
So even with the delays,
that's a good hour and a half.
And so I think maybe we'll call it a day
and um,
I didn't get too many questions,
although some of them were very,
very complicated.
And I would like to thank you for tuning
in and maybe I can remind you again
about self authoring Dotcom and
understand myself.com and the discount
coupon code September.
So if you guys want to try out those
programs,
I think they're real helpful and I think
that's how people experience them.
Then you can do that.
And then all have another q and a
probably I would say probably in mid
October because I'm on the road now.
You can see that in Jordan B.
Peterson.
Dot.
Call Matt Events.
Um,
I'm on the road now until mid October.
And so I'll do another q and a then and
hopefully have an update on the
educational progress of the educational
material and all of that.
And so,
um,
thanks very much for tuning in and,
uh,
I hope you enjoyed the discussion.
It got quite well far beyond what I
thought it would get too.
I haven't talked about that newness
Mundus idea for a long time and it's
very,
very radical idea.
It's sort of central.
That idea is central,
I would say,
or at least central in an implicit sense
to maps of meaning and God fucking
thing.
Yeah.
All right,
well look,
obviously the technological problems are
mounting it exponentially by all
appearances.
So I'm going to call it a night.
Thank you very much.
And uh,
good luck to all of you.
Get your lives together,
man.
It's,
it'd be a good thing for everyone,
including you,
but also everyone else and maybe the
structure of the world itself.
I really believe that's true by the way.
So for what that's worth.
Okay,
guys.
Bye.
Okay.